I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi everyone.
Howdy?
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节和大量的闺蜜故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。大家好。嗨？
We can't believe we're saying this, but I mean.
Really, truly.
We're fan-girling because.
You guys, Billy Eilish is back on the podcast today.
By her request.
She reached out to us.
I mean, lady, maybe we're cool.
We're 100% cool now.
我们真不敢相信自己在说这个，我是说。真的，千真万确。我们化身小粉丝了，因为。各位，比利·艾莉丝今天又做客我们的播客了。这是她要求的。她主动联系了我们。我的意思是，女士，也许我们很酷。我们现在百分之百很酷了。
We are now, yeah.
It's official.
Well, listen, she is an incredible person.
She was in the studio with us today.
She also brought along her dog shark.
And she talks about some of her favorite all-time moments from the office.
those were just so amazing to hear.
我们现在是了，是的。这是官方的。这是官方的。好吧，听着，她是一个不可思议的人。她今天和我们一起在录音室里。她还带来了她的狗鲨鱼。她谈到了她最喜欢的《办公室》历史时刻中的一些。听到这些真是太棒了。
She really knows the show.
She knows the show.
I mean, there are this super office fandom group
that they know the show backwards and forwards.
They can quote the show.
They know the world.
They love the world.
And Billy is in that group of people.
她真的很懂这部剧。她懂这部剧。我的意思是，存在这样一个超级办公室粉丝群体，他们对这部剧倒背如流。他们能引用剧中的台词。他们了解这个世界。他们热爱这个世界。比利就是这群人中的一员。
Yes.
And I loved talking about her favorite moments with her.
And we also talked about her new live concert movie,
which just came out.
hit me hard and soft in 3D, a movie that she co-directed with James Cameron.
She tells us about that.
And Billy wanted to do another round of trivia.
Yes, because the first time she was on the podcast, we did office trivia.
是的。我很喜欢和她聊她最喜欢的时刻。我们还聊了她刚刚上映的全新演唱会电影。在3D中重击我心，一部她与詹姆斯·卡梅隆共同执导的电影。她给我们讲述了那部电影。比利还想进行另一轮问答。是的，因为她第一次上播客时，我们玩了办公室问答。
She kicked our butts.
Yes.
Yeah.
So this time she enlisted her friend Jack, who called in, and we tried to think of some of just the hardest deep cut questions.
And wow.
Well, you'll hear how it goes.
Mm-hmm. So without further ado, please enjoy our conversation with the awesome Billy Eilish.
All right, you guys, we're so excited because Billy Eilish is here with us today.
她把我们打得落花流水。没错。是的。所以这次她请来了她的朋友杰克，他打电话进来了，我们试着想出一些最难、最冷门的题目。然后，哇。好吧，你会听到结果如何。嗯。那么废话不多说，请欣赏我们与了不起的比利·艾莉丝的对话。好了，各位，我们非常兴奋，因为比利·艾莉丝今天和我们在一起。
Yes.
Hi, Billie. This is so great. Hi, guys. I begged them let me back on the show, so here I am back on the show.
Billy, we're not even believe you want to hang out with us, truly.
I called Cameron, who's sitting over there, and I was like, hey, I know office ladies are at that.
You know, I already went on. I had my time, but can I go back?
Can I please go back on?
And I have so many things to say, and I'm going to get into it.
But I'm so happy to be here right now.
是的。嗨，比利。太棒了。嗨，伙计们，我求他们让我再上节目的，所以我又上节目了。比利，我们甚至不敢相信你想跟我们混在一起，真的。我给坐在那里的卡梅隆打电话说，嘿，我知道办公室女士们在做那个。你知道，我已经去过了。我有过我的时间，但我能回去吗？我能请回去吗？我有太多话要说，我要切入正题了。但我现在太高兴能来到这里了。
It was the most exciting email ever.
I was in a dressing room at the mall, and I yelped.
You did not.
I did.
I was like, ah!
And then I immediately am side texting Angela.
Angela, check your email.
And I was driving, so I'm like, I can't see the email.
这是有史以来最让人兴奋的邮件。当时我在商场的更衣室里，我尖叫了一声。你才没有。我真的叫了。我当时想，啊！然后我立刻给安吉拉发短信。安吉拉，查收邮件。当时我在开车，所以我想，我看不见邮件。
What is it?
Yeah.
We're very excited to have you.
Well, I have one thing to say that is really, really crazy to hear.
hear myself say and the fact that it's true.
Shark stop it.
Shark's here.
Shark is here.
是什么？是的。我们非常高兴你能来。好吧，我有一件事要说，听到自己说出来真的很疯狂，而且这是真的。鲨鱼，别闹了。鲨鱼在这儿。鲨鱼在这儿。
Yeah, he's crying in the corners.
But I obviously was nervous last time I came because it's you guys and it's the office,
which is like my oxygen.
And there's that.
But today I have to tell you something, which is that I listen to office ladies more than I
watch the office.
I'm out.
是的，它在角落里哭呢。但上次来的时候我显然很紧张，因为是你们，还有《办公室》，这就像是我的氧气。就是这样。但今天我得告诉你一件事，那就是我听《办公室女士》的频率比我看《办公室》还要高。我要疯了。我要疯了。
That is amazing.
More, and by the way, I have listened to every single episode of your entire podcast.
You're kidding me. Stop it.
By the way, because I'm obviously obsessed with you in this incredible show that has changed my life forever.
Like, I've seen the show so many times that I know what I'm watching.
And I listened to obviously these, like I'm, I listen to it as soon as I wake up, when I get ready for the day, when I get dressed, when I'm driving, when I'm packing, when.
when I'm cleaning.
I listen to it every single night to fall asleep,
太惊人了。而且，顺便说一句，我听了你们整个播客的每一集。你在开玩笑吧。别闹了。顺便说一句，因为我显然对你和这部改变了我一生的不可思议的剧集着迷。比如，这部剧我看过太多遍了，我知道我在看什么。而且我显然听这些，就像我是，我一醒来就听，为一天做准备时听，穿衣服时听，开车时听，收拾行李时听，当。我在打扫卫生时听。我每天晚上都听着它入睡，
every single night,
and I have listened to every single episode,
except like when you talk about, like, Star Wars.
I'm sorry.
You have to listen to Star Wars.
It's really craptastic.
Okay, the holiday.
Star Wars movie, though, is so bad.
每天晚上都听，而且我听了每一集，除了你们谈论像《星球大战》这样的内容的时候。对不起。你们必须听听《星球大战》。这真的很逊。好吧，不过节日《星球大战》电影真的很烂。
It's so good.
We won't do the other ones.
Okay, but I had to just say
that I now listen to your podcast more than
watch the office. And just so you know, to give you context, I've never done anything more than
watch the office. Because I started listening, like, after we did our podcast, and then I've listened
to every single episode you guys have put out since 2019, God damn it. And literally up until I am 29
minutes into second drink of employee transfer, which you put out 13 hours ago. So I'm fully up to
它太棒了。我们不会做其他的。好吧，我只是想说，我现在听你们播客的频率比看《办公室》还要高。为了让你们有个概念，我从没做过比看《办公室》更多的事。因为我开始听，就像在我们做完播客之后，然后我听了你们自2019年以来发布的每一集，该死的。老实说，直到我听到了第二杯员工调动，那是你们13小时前发布的，我已经听了29分钟。所以我完全跟上进度了。
date. I am dying. Every single episode. Hearing both of your voices right now is like very confusing
for me because I hear them every day all day like this, not in the office, like this.
And Sam being here, I'm like, Sam, I feel like I know so much about you, Sam.
Because weren't you here when I was here?
Yes.
Because like I didn't even think.
Sam is day one.
That's insane.
我快死了。每一集。现在听到你们两个的声音对我来说非常困惑，因为我每天整天都听到它们，就像这样，不是在办公室里，就像这样。山姆在这里，我觉得，山姆，我觉得我对你了解得太多了，山姆。因为我来的时候你不是也在这里吗？是的。因为我甚至没想过。山姆是第一天就在的元老。这太疯狂了。
I mean, I know that now.
From airwulfs with us.
But I don't, I was like, oh, hey, Sam.
You know, when I met you the first time and now I have all this lore about you, Sam.
And I'm like, I know all about Cassie.
and I'm like, I just, I know everything, and I am as much a fan of office ladies as I am of the office.
And so, yeah, anyway, that's my thing.
That's my spiel.
我的意思是，我现在知道了。和我们一起开飞狼。但我不知道，我当时想，哦，嗨，山姆。你知道，我第一次见到你的时候，现在我有了关于你的所有传说，山姆。我就想，我对卡茜了如指掌。我就想，我只是，我什么都知道，我对办公室女士们的喜爱和对《办公室》的喜爱是一样的。所以，是的，不管怎样，这就是我的事。这就是我的长篇大论。
And that's why I needed to get the hell in here.
Well, first of all, I'm speechless, which is rare, because that was so sweet.
And I'm going to live on that for a long time.
Well, are you still watching the office at all?
I'm still watching the office, but I watch the office now more as like a TV thing.
because it used to be my podcast.
Like, it used to be a...
You used to listen to it inside.
这就是我非得闯进来的原因。好吧，首先，我无言以对，这很少见，因为这太甜了。我要靠这个活好久了。好吧，你还在看《办公室》吗？我还在看《办公室》，但我现在看《办公室》更多是把它当成一个电视节目。因为过去它是我的播客。就像它曾经是一个……你以前是在里面听的。
I'm like in your pocket.
Yes, I would put it in my pocket.
Yeah.
I mean, I still do that.
I did that last night.
I've been like putting up frames on my walls and like putting up pictures and I've been like drilling them into the walls.
And so I put my phone in my pocket and I'm like, I'm carrying things around my house.
And usually it used to be the office playing because I know what it looks like.
我就像在你的口袋里。是的，我会把它放进口袋里。是的。我的意思是，我到现在还这么做。我昨晚就这么做了。我一直在墙上挂画框，贴照片，我一直在把它们钉进墙里。所以我把手机放进口袋里，我想，我在屋子里搬东西。通常以前都是播放《办公室》，因为我知道它长什么样。
I just need to hear it to like visualize it because I have it all memorized.
And now it's you guys.
I watch The Office now as a little dessert, like a little gift to myself.
It's more of a watching TV than it used to be.
Are you still going in order?
Or do you jump around now?
I still go in order.
I can't really jump around because I'm watching the super fan episodes.
我只需要听到它就能在脑海中想象出来，因为我都背下来了。现在是你们了。我现在看《办公室》就像吃一份小甜点，就像给自己的一个小礼物。它比以前更像是在看电视了。你还在按顺序看吗？还是现在会跳着看？我还是按顺序看。我没法真的跳着看，因为我在看超级粉丝版剧集。
I was going to ask you that.
Are you watching them?
Of course.
I mean, I think Dave Rogers, you know.
Dave Rogers, absolutely.
He's like done an amazing job.
Amazing job.
I think it was fun run that the deleted scenes were so.
我正要问你这个。你在看吗？当然。我的意思是，我认为戴夫·罗杰斯，你知道的。戴夫·罗杰斯，绝对的。他干得太棒了。太棒了。我想那是欢乐跑，被删减的场景太……
amazing. That's on his list of his 10 favorites. It's amazing. And the whole episode, I was like,
these are so good. Yeah. And then, yeah, there's like some episodes with so many deleted scenes where
you're like, whoa. Whoa. Yeah. Interesting. And like deleted scenes are just little snippets of
moments that he finds that are nonverbal. I love. Like so good. So good. Like, so many more like
looks around like people like clocking what Michael's doing or whatever. Also, like you have said this about
the super fan episodes that is what one thing that's so interesting is so many of the scenes that
are added are the scenes in the shots that were in the original episode but like lengthened on either
side yeah yeah where it's like you didn't even know there was more to that scene that you've seen
太棒了。那是他最喜欢的10个片段之一。太棒了。整集我都觉得，这些太棒了。是的。然后，是的，有些剧集有那么多被删减的场景，你会觉得，哇。哇。是的，很有趣。而且被删减的场景只是他找到的非语言时刻的一些小片段。我太喜欢了。太棒了。比如，有更多环顾四周的镜头，比如人们注意到迈克尔在做什么之类的。还有，就像你关于超级粉丝版剧集所说的那样，有一点非常有趣，那就是添加的许多场景都是原剧集中的镜头和画面，但在两端延长了，是的，是的，就好像你甚至不知道你看了永远的那个场景还有更多内容一样
forever which has been like really amazing so i'm currently i've watched everything but season
nine because those just came out so i'm about to start season nine of the super fan episodes but i keep like
going back to the beginning and then like if people are watching with me, I will go to like season
four because it's just so good that it's undeniable just to make sure everyone knows how incredible
it is.
So yeah.
I'm rewatching with my kids.
So this will be my second rewatch.
这真是太神奇了，所以我目前，除了第九季我都看过了，因为那些刚出来，所以我准备开始看超级粉丝版的第九季了，但我总是一直回到开头，然后如果有人跟我一起看，我会切到第四季，因为它实在是太好了，无可否认，只是为了确保每个人都知道它有多不可思议。所以，是的。我和我的孩子们一起重温。所以这将是我的第二次重温。
Amazing.
We are in the middle of season five.
I can't remember where we just ended.
but I really love season four and five.
They're unbeatable.
They are so good.
Like, goodbye Toby.
太棒了。我们正处于第五季的中期。我记不清我们刚刚在哪里结束了。但我真的很喜欢第四季和第五季。它们是无可匹敌的。它们太棒了。它们太棒了。比如，再见托比。
When I knew that Michael was going to do his song,
I didn't even watch the TV.
I just watched my kids.
Because I love it when he's like,
he's out of here.
Toby's going away.
Like I love it.
See ya.
当我得知迈克尔要唱歌时，我甚至没有看电视。我只是看着我的孩子们。因为我喜欢当他那样的时候，他要离开这里了。托比要走了。就像我喜欢的那样。再见。
I love it.
Oh, my God.
it's so good. Yeah. It's so exciting, too, that your kids get to relive it with you and also
see this thing that is on camera forever that you get to watch. It's just amazing. And then
their kids will be able to watch. Oh, my gosh. That's crazy to be about it. It is wild, and we've
talked about this, and you've probably heard me say this, but when your kids' friends who have always
known you is just like Isabel's mom, and then all of a sudden you're Angela Martin to them, and they're
like, whoa, what?
我太喜欢了。哦，天哪。太棒了。这也太令人兴奋了，你的孩子们能和你一起重温，还能看到这个永远在摄像机上记录下来的、供你观看的东西。这简直太神奇了。然后他们的孩子也可以观看。哦，天哪。想想就觉得疯狂。这太疯狂了，我们谈论过这个，你可能也听我这么说过，但是当你的孩子们的朋友一直只把你当成伊莎贝拉的妈妈，然后突然之间在他们眼里你成了安吉拉·马丁，他们就会想，哇，什么？
I'm like, you guys want a snack?
And they're like, you're just like, it's really wild.
It's so wild.
It just, because it just, the view changes.
It's like me with Sam.
I'm like, wait, Sam is here?
I know so much about Sam.
You have to say hi.
我就说，你们想吃点零食吗？然后他们就觉得，你简直就像，这真的太疯狂了。太疯狂了。只是，因为视角变了。就像我和山姆一样。我就想，等等，山姆在这里？我对山姆了解得太多了。你得打个招呼。
Hi.
Hi, Sam.
I know your voice so well.
It's good to meet you again.
Wow.
Amazing.
This is insane.
嗨。嗨，山姆。嗨。我对你的声音太熟悉了。很高兴再次见到你。哇。太神奇了。这太疯狂了。
And this is how all fans of office ladies specifically feel is like,
Like, you guys are with me through everything.
Like, everything I'm going through, at least I have you guys.
And what's really been crazy is I was in my house.
I was, like, cleaning something or, you know, this is a while ago.
This is when I was like halfway through all of your episodes.
And I hear like, oh, by the way, Billy Eilish said, did it.
And I went like, because I'm like, I forgot for a second.
所有《办公室》的粉丝都有这种感觉，就好像，你们一直陪着我经历一切。比如，我经历的所有事情，至少有你们陪伴。真正疯狂的是，当时我在家里。我当时在，比如，打扫卫生，或者，你知道的，这已经是一段时间前了。那是当我差不多听完你们所有节目的一半的时候。然后我听到，哦，顺便说一句，比利·艾利什说，她看了。然后我整个人，因为我一下子给忘了。
You just broke your phone for a wall.
Whoa.
And then that happened multiple.
times. And then because I'm letting them play and play and play, I have them all in my queue. So I'm not
looking at which one is coming next. And so then it's like, guess who's here today? And then my
voice appears and I hear, hi, guys. And I'm like sitting in my living room. Oh my God. Like, it's the
most trippy thing because obviously I experienced doing that with you guys. But I literally am Isabel's
你差点把手机砸到墙上。哇。哇。然后这种事发生了很多次。然后因为我让它们一直播放、播放、播放，我都把它们加在播放队列里了。所以我并没有看接下来播放的是哪一个。然后突然听到，猜猜今天谁来了？接着我的声音出现了，我听到，嗨，伙计们。我当时正坐在起居室里。哦，天哪。这简直是最迷幻的事情，因为很明显，我经历过和你们一起录音的过程。但我现在完全成了伊莎贝尔的
friends. Like I feel like I have this whole new like view of it. And it's just the most insane.
same thing in the world. Oh, God. Well, okay, first of all, last time you're here, we said you can come
back anytime. That invitation stands. So anytime, here I am. Correct. And we be careful what you
for, seriously. Well, we wanted to talk to you about some of your favorite The Office moments.
And you actually said there's almost so many. There's so many. But we were going to try to narrow it down to
three today. Okay. We can try. Well, that is a really hard question. I like,
spent the whole week, like, writing down everything and, like, scrolling through every episode
to, like, make sure that I had the right ones. Okay, so I'm going to try to narrow it down.
朋友。就好像我对它有了一个全新视角。这简直是世界上最疯狂的事情。哦，天哪。好吧，首先，上次你来的时候，我们说过你随时可以再来。这个邀请依然有效。所以随时来，我这不就来了。没错。当心你许下的愿望，说真的。嗯，我们想和你聊聊你最喜欢的《办公室》时刻。你其实说过几乎有太多了。有太多了。但我们今天要试着把它们缩小到三个。好吧。我们可以试试。嗯，这真的是个很难的问题。我喜欢，花了一整周的时间，写下所有东西，然后，滚动浏览每一集，以确保我选对了。好吧，那我尽量精简一下。
First of all, one of the most incredible scenes. Oh, God. Okay, wait, I'm going to say two and one
because they're similar. I literally can see your brain, like, going through a Rolodex.
No, actually Rolodex brain right now, because I have so many. Okay. Jenna.
Yes. God damn it.
Two scenes that are absolutely some of the most incredible acting I've ever seen in my life
and undeniably the most incredible between you and John acting that's ever been given to us
as a people in the world.
Specifically when he confesses that he's in love with you,
首先，其中一个最不可思议的场景。哦，天哪。好吧，等等，我要把两个合成一个，因为它们很相似。我简直能看到你的大脑，在快速翻阅索引卡片。不，其实现在就是个索引卡片大脑，因为我有太多了。好吧。珍娜。是的。该死。两个场景绝对是我这辈子看过最不可思议的表演，毫无疑问也是你和约翰之间为我们全世界人民呈现过最不可思议的表演。特别是当他向你表白他爱上你的时候，
that is one of the most groundbreaking scenes to me and like iconic.
and it's such a basic answer
because it's such an amazing scene.
Everything about it is so special
and on that same note,
jumping ahead,
when you do your talking head
when he's doing his interview for Stamford,
对我来说，那是具有划时代意义的场景之一，而且超级经典。这是一个很基础的答案，因为它真的是个太棒的场景了。关于它的一切都那么特别。顺着这个思路，跳到后面，当你在斯坦福德面试时做那个访谈的时候，
you know you killed that whole...
I feel like if I were you,
I would be like, yeah, that was pretty fucking good.
That was pretty good.
Of any moment on the office,
that is like my best moment.
And I know it.
Like I know.
你知道你把那段……我觉得如果我是你，我就会想，是的，这演得真他妈好。这演得太棒了。在《办公室》的所有时刻中，这绝对是我高光时刻。而且我知道。就像我心里有数一样。
You better know it.
Pretty great.
Like everything that comes across your face is just phenomenal.
And also not only do you know it, but Ken Kwapas knew it too.
Yeah.
And he's just everyone.
Everyone knew it.
It's obvious.
你最好心里有数。相当棒。你脸上的每一个表情都无与伦比。不仅你知道，肯·夸皮斯也知道。对。而且他就是每个人。每个人都知道。这显而易见。
Can I tell you that I was scrolling Instagram recently and someone posted that the reason
I gave that performance was because I didn't know John was going to come in the door
and deliver that line?
When they make that stuff up.
And it's not true, everybody.
I knew it was in the script.
It was meticulously timed.
But not only that, she had to do that take multiple times.
我跟你说，我最近在刷 Instagram 时，看到有人发帖说，我之所以能演出那种效果，是因为我不知道约翰会推门进来并说出那句台词？他们真会瞎编。大家听好了，这不是真的。我知道剧本里有。那是经过精确计演的。不仅如此，那个镜头她还得拍好几次。
Yeah.
Of course.
She knew he was coming.
I knew he was coming.
No shit.
You're just an amazing actor.
Yeah.
You know, everyone loves him.
对。当然。她知道他要来。我知道他要来。废话。你只是个优秀的演员。对。你知道的，每个人都喜欢他。
Of course he's going to get the job.
And, you know, we never got the timing right.
I shot him down.
He did the same to me.
But it's fine.
Everything's going to be.
And you turn.
And there he is.
他当然会得到这份工作。而且，你知道，我们一直没对准时机。我拒绝了他。他也对我做了同样的事。但没关系。一切都会。然后你转过身。他就在那里。
Are you free for dinner?
tonight, you go yes, and he says it's a date. You turn back to the camera and your eyes have
filled with tears. I don't know how I did it. I don't know. I did it either. Like, how did you do that?
When I turned back, the look on Ken Kwapis's face, he was next to the camera. He was our director
for that episode. He looked at me. It's insane. He'd been with us since the pilot. He felt like our
dad and like having that moment where your dad is like, you did it, kid. You know when something
means something to you, it's really moving. But when you can lock eyes with someone who knows
just as well what it means to you, then you lose it. And so the fact that the Pam inside of me
今晚有空一起吃晚饭吗？你回答有，他说这算是一次约会。你转回镜头前，眼里充满泪水。我不知道我是怎么做到的。我也不知道我是怎么做到的。就像，你是怎么做到的？当我转过身时，肯·夸皮斯脸上的表情，他就站在摄像机旁边。他是那一集的导演。他看着我。这太疯狂了。从试播集开始他就一直和我们在一起。他感觉就像我们的父亲，那种时刻——就好像你的父亲对你说，你做到了，孩子。你知道当某件事对你意义重大时，它真的很感人。但当你能和一个同样深知它对你意味着什么的人四目相对时，你就会彻底破防。所以，我内心深处的帕姆
was getting all of her wishes come true in that moment, but then I could look in the eyes of someone
else who knew that all of Pam's wishes were coming true. That is what did it. If I had
to look at a tennis ball, I can't say that you would have gotten the same thing.
So there was like, there was another performance happening off camera that was helping me.
It's just so amazing. And when you did that, I mean, because you had to do multiple takes.
I don't understand how one can recreate this. Also, because it's not like, you know,
a scene where you're starting it out crying. It's like that's a whole other hard thing.
But it's like doing the same scene over and over where you're starting out totally normal and unaffected and then switching over.
在那个时刻所有的愿望都成真了，然后我能看着另一个人的眼睛，那个人知道帕姆所有的愿望都在成真。这就是起作用的原因。如果我不得不对着一个网球演，我不敢说你能得到相同的效果。所以当时镜头外还有另一场表演在协助我。这真是太神奇了。当你那样做的时候，我是说，因为你必须拍好几个镜头。我不明白一个人怎么能重新创造这个。而且，这不像是那种你一开始就在哭的场景。那是另一个难点。这就像是一次又一次地拍同一场戏，你一开始完全正常、无动于衷，然后情绪转换过来。
It's just like so amazing.
And I just can't give you enough props.
It's just so magical and you're so incredible.
Thank you.
I actually think it's easier to do starting to not cry and to crying because if the writing is right and if you know your character, then the truth of it should make the emotion come.
I've had to do scenes.
Like I had to do that scene where I'm just like sobbing in the hallway and then Dwight comes up to me.
It was so much harder to get myself to that state from zero, from nothing.
这简直太神奇了。我怎么夸你都不为过。这太魔幻了，你太不可思议了。谢谢。其实我觉得从不哭到哭比较容易演，因为如果剧本写得对，如果你了解你的角色，那么其中的真实感自然会带出情绪。我拍过一些戏。比如我必须拍那种我在走廊里嚎啕大哭然后德怀特走过来的戏。从零开始、从什么都没有的状态让自己进入那种情绪，要难得多。
That's crazy.
That's when you have to like listen to sad music and like all that.
And like stay away from everyone between scenes doing bits.
Right.
And I know that everyone kind of left you alone and let you have that to fully get into it.
And it's just so amazing and moving.
And I'm also obsessed with that your song.
to get you, I think then
太疯狂了。那是你不得不听悲伤的音乐之类的。而且在两场戏之间远离所有人，不搞怪。对。我知道每个人都有点让你一个人待着，让你完全沉浸其中。这真的太神奇、太感人了。而且我也超级痴迷于你的歌，为了得到你，我想当时
it was the, please, please,
let me get what I want cover by...
Who was it, Deftones or something insane?
I think that's right, yeah.
That's an insane choice, Jenna.
It's an amazingly insane, amazing.
Like, by the way,
please, please, please, let me get what I want
那是，请，请，让我得到我想要的，翻唱自……是谁，得世乐队（Deftones）还是什么疯狂的乐队？我想是的，没错。这是一个疯狂的选择，珍娜。这是一个惊人地疯狂、美妙的选择。顺便说一句，请，请，请，让我得到我想要的
by the Smiths is an incredible song
and it is so heartbreaking.
And when you said that, I thought,
wow, that's an amazing choice.
And I thought, oh, I haven't heard Deftones version.
I listen to it.
And it's like
And I'm like so hard.
史密斯乐队（The Smiths）的歌是一首不可思议的歌，而且它太让人心碎了。当你这么说的时候，我想，哇，这真是一个绝妙的选择。我想，哦，我还没听过得世乐队的版本。我去听了。然后就感觉，简直太戳了。
Jeff, hell yeah.
That's just I love
because music does have that effect.
This one is a metal head.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
My son is.
And so by default,
杰夫，太棒了。我太喜欢了，因为音乐确实有这种魔力。这位是个金属迷。太棒了。对。我儿子是。所以顺理成章地，
I have now,
it's amazing.
It's just so magical.
And okay,
moving it along because I have more,
I have more moments.
That was like one and a halfish of.
Yeah.
我现在，这太神奇了。这简直太魔幻了。好了，接着往下说，因为我还有，我还有更多精彩片段。那大概是一集半的量。对。
There was a lot of moments.
I'm just saying, really.
Okay.
In my most recent rewatch, because I'm listening to you guys talk about each episode,
I'm really watching them more closely now because now I know so much behind the scenes of it,
which is so fun and interesting and exciting.
And Angela, you just are just gold to the show.
有太多精彩时刻了。我只是说说，真的。好吧。好吧。在我最近的重温中，因为我在听你们聊每一集，我现在看剧看得更仔细了，因为现在我知道了那么多幕后故事，这真的很有趣、很刺激、很令人兴奋。安吉拉，你简直就是这部剧里的无价之宝。
It's just like the amount of times that we watch this show, and I'm like, wait for it.
And then you just say something with the most perfect.
Delivery. And it's so interesting because I know how different you are from Angela Martin.
And now you're not that cold, you know, you're this bubbly angel of a person. And it is pretty
upsetting how incredible you are at playing that kind of a character. And I know that you talked about
how you've always kind of before that played like a beat and fun light characters. And like on New Girl,
you're like, yeah, okay, you know, just this like light kind of owly.
You have owl eyes, like what you say in there.
就像我们看这部剧的次数，然后我会想，等一下。然后你就用最完美的语气说出了一句话。这就很有趣，因为我知道你和安吉拉·马丁有多么不同。现在你可没那么冷酷，你知道的，你是一个充满活力的天使般的人。你把那种角色演得如此出神入化，这简直让人有点难以置信。我知道你谈到过在拍这部剧之前你总是扮演那种活泼、有趣、轻松的角色。就像在《杰茜驾到》里，你就像是，好吧，你知道的，就像这种轻松的、有点像猫头鹰一样的。你有猫头鹰一样的眼睛，就像你在里面说的那样。
Anyway, moving on.
So I feel like I know you so well now based on this show.
And it's just even more impressive.
And like, okay, specific lines of yours that kill me and that we quote all the time is like
when Michael is in the bullpen and he's trying to.
to kind of derail everyone from knowing that some of them aren't going to get raises or that all
the raises are going to be smaller. And he's like, yes, lend Oscar a cup of sugar. And you go,
what are you talking about, Michael? It's literally like the most incredible delivery of a line ever in
不管怎样，继续。所以我觉得通过这个节目我现在对你太了解了。这甚至更加让人印象深刻。好吧，你那些让我笑死并且我们经常引用的经典台词，比如迈克尔在办公区试图转移大家的注意力，不让大家知道他们有些人不会加薪，或者所有人的加薪都会减少。然后他说，对，借给奥斯卡一杯糖。而你回答，你在说什么，迈克尔？这简直是史上最不可思议的一句台词演绎
life. Also, like, the amount of times that you, like, in the conference room just add like an, oh.
And it just, it always makes me laugh out loud.
And your ability to be so cruel is uncanny and unbelievable and so moving.
And also like just every time like Kevin pushes by you and you completely fall, it's just, it kills me.
I'm like getting flustered and I'm trying to think of like more specific moments.
Wait, I have them written down.
Please.
Hold on.
还有，比如你在会议室里加上一声，哦，的次数。这总是让我放声大笑。你那种能够表现得如此冷酷无情的能力真是出神入化、难以置信而且太感人了。还有就像每次凯文从你身边挤过去而你完全摔倒，这简直要了我的命。我都有点慌乱了，我想想还有什么更具体的时刻。等等，我都写下来了。请。等一下。
You mentioned crime aid.
Oh, my gosh.
Freaking.
Crime aid.
Your favorite moment from crime aid, I love so much that I asked Matt Beagle and Sam to pull it as a clip if we wanted to hear it.
Because it's that thing.
You love something that we both love is when Michael doesn't know what he's saying, but he's trying to make a point.
And he's just meandering all over the place.
你提到了犯罪日。哦，天哪。该死的。犯罪日。你最喜欢的犯罪日桥段，我太喜欢了，以至于我让马特·比格尔和山姆把它剪成了一个片段，如果我们想听的话。因为就是那种东西。你喜欢的东西也是我们俩都喜欢的，那就是迈克尔不知道自己在说什么，但他又想阐明一个观点。结果他就东拉西扯、毫无重点。
This is one of my favorite Michael moments of all time because Steve Correll, just anything that comes out of
his mouth is gold. And really like every line of his is my favorite of the entire show. And
specifically like what you're saying, when he's like, sometimes I just start a sentence.
The dual? And I just hope I find it. I just don't know where it's going, but just maybe I'll find it
along the way. That's one of my favorite things in the world. And you can just see that happen
over and over and over. Imagine this. You're in the conference room with us. I can't even.
Steve is going to have a meandering speech, and then he just starts freestyling it, like just throwing in some extra random thoughts.
And that would be it.
这是我最喜欢的迈克尔经典时刻之一，因为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，他嘴里说出来的任何东西都是无价之宝。真的，他的每一句台词都是我整部剧中最喜欢的。特别是像你所说的，当他说，有时我只是开始说一句话。两难？我只希望我能找到它。我只是不知道它会通往何方，但也许我会在过程中找到它。这是我世界上最喜欢的事情之一。你可以看到这种情景一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地上演。想象一下这个。你和我们一起在会议室里。我简直不敢想象。史蒂夫会有一段漫无边际的演讲，然后他开始自由发挥，比如随兴加入一些额外的随机想法。这就成了。
I'd be like, I can't even handle it.
All right, all right.
Well, let's listen.
Okay.
So in order to recoup the value of items we liked, we have to spend more money on things we don't want.
Who would ever come to this?
I don't know.
It could be any number of people.
我会觉得，我简直承受不了。好了，好了。好吧，我们听听看。好吧。所以为了弥补我们喜欢的东西的价值，我们不得不把更多的钱花在我们不想要的东西上。谁会想出这个？我不知道。这可以是任何人。
It could be a pedestrian.
It could be a loopie loo.
It could be a Lukie Lou.
Or it could be a Bruce Springsteen fan.
What?
Who said that?
I did.
Well, why did I say that?
可能是个行人。可能是个疯子。可能是个路基·娄。或者也可能是个布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的粉丝。什么？谁说的？我说的。好吧，我为什么这么说？
Oh, I think you know why I said that.
I think it's very apparent.
I think it goes without saying, bear with me.
There's a point there.
But what is the point?
I don't understand what he's saying.
It seems a little shady.
It seems a little foggy.
哦，我想你知道我为什么这么说。我觉得这很明显。我觉得不言而喻，请耐心听我说。里面有个点。但重点是什么？我不明白他在说什么。感觉有点可疑。感觉有点扑朔迷离。
Oh, my gosh.
Well, it's not a little foggy.
There's really something going on.
Do you need us for any of this?
Do I?
Do you need us for?
ready at this.
Do I?
哦，天哪。好吧，这可不只是有点扑朔迷离。这背后真的有什么猫腻。你们任何事情都需要我们吗？我吗？你们需要我们来……准备好这个。我吗？
Oh my God, that kills me.
Another really quick moment
that is like that
when he's like,
the head of a monkey
and the body.
That's the moment
I could not recover from.
哦天哪，这笑死我了。另一个让我印象深刻的瞬间是，当他说到，猴子的头和身体。那就是我缓不过劲来的时刻。
Because he just started throwing
out all kinds of animal combinations
that weren't scripted.
And it just goes way too long.
Also, there's like long pauses.
So you're like,
what animal is he can say?
Yes.
因为他开始抛出各种剧本里没有的动物组合。而且这持续的时间也太长了。另外，中间还有很长的停顿。所以你会想，他接下来会说出什么动物？是的。
We don't know.
It's just the most amazing thing.
His brain just works
in a way that I just don't understand.
One other moment that I just remember just now
is one of my all-time favorites
is when Ed Truck dies.
And he's like, it feels like
我们不知道。这简直是最神奇的事情。他的脑回路就是让我无法理解。我刚刚突然想起的另一个时刻，也是我历来最喜欢的时刻之一，就是埃德·特拉克去世的时候。他说，感觉就像
someone dropped, I think,
my soul or my heart into a bucket of boiling tears.
And then someone else comes in
and starts, you know, punching me in the grief bone.
And he's just like making stuff up.
but then it just always ends up being so heartbreaking and touching.
I know.
And it just kills me.
有人把，我觉得，我的灵魂或心脏扔进了一桶沸腾的眼泪里。然后另一个人走过来开始，你知道的，痛击我的悲伤骨。他就是这样即兴胡编乱造。但最后总是显得那么心碎和感人。我懂。这简直要了我的命。
Anyway, I could literally go on forever.
I mean, it's interesting that you two are the ones with this podcast because obviously you two
are best friends and you're such hard workers and you make this show because it's a passion
of yours.
But you happen to be two of the most important parts of this show, The Office, and two of the
greatest actresses I've ever seen. And your performances in this show specifically are just so
incredible and just having it be you to is just really special. And everyone in the office is
incredible. But it's just, I don't know, I think I've just been more aware, I think,
总之，我真的可以滔滔不绝地说上一整天。我的意思是，很有趣的是，你们两个居然是这个播客的主持人，因为很显然你们俩是最好的朋友，你们工作如此努力，做这个节目是因为这是你们的热情所在。但你们恰好也是《办公室》这部剧中最最重要的两个部分，以及我见过的最伟大的两位女演员。你们在这部剧中的表现简直是太不可思议了，而且由你们俩来出演真的非常特别。办公室里的每个人都很了不起。但这就，我不知道，我觉得我最近
recently of how incredible you are and noticing it throughout and just being like, wow, I
can't believe how good Angela is. Anyway, let me stop. Well, I mean. Just take it in. Just let me say it and take it. I'm just trying to take it. I'm trying to take it. Before we move on, I do want to talk about your love of Michael's birthday because you mentioned that. My mother was rubbing cream on me for probably three hours.
Those talking heads. I mean, we were just talking about how it's like there's these talking heads and they're like funny, but they're also like, oh, Michael, particularly when he's talking about.
about his childhood or his family.
Oh, God, I can't.
I know.
So, I can't deal with it.
But you found a candy bag all for Michael's birthday.
越来越意识到你们有多么了不起，在整部剧中都能注意到这一点，然后就会想，哇，我真不敢相信安吉拉这么优秀。总之，让我打住吧。好吧，我是说。好好享受。就让我说出来并接受吧。我正努力接受呢。我正努力接受呢。在我们继续之前，我还想聊聊你对迈克尔生日的喜爱，因为你提到了那个。我妈妈给我抹了大概三个小时的药膏。那些独白镜头。我的意思是，我们刚才还在讨论这些独白镜头是什么样的，它们既搞笑，但又会让人觉得，哦，迈克尔，尤其是当他谈到他的童年或他的家庭时。哦，天哪，我受不了。我懂。所以，我没法面对这个。但你竟然为迈克尔的生日找到了一整袋糖果。
So you know, Michael has these talking heads about his worst birthdays.
Yes.
So here's one that was in the script, but was not used.
Michael would say, on my 20th birthday, my supposed a best friend, Sam Ambrose,
ditched me for his twin sister's sweet 16 party like I didn't want to go.
That was my worst birthday until today.
It's that whole runner of it being his worst birthday.
It's just, they're all so, so tough to listen.
所以你知道的，迈克尔有一些关于他最糟糕生日的独白。是的。所以这里有一个剧本里有但没有被采用的片段。迈克尔会说，在我20岁生日那天，我所谓的最好朋友萨姆·安布罗斯为了他双胞胎姐姐的16岁甜蜜派对而抛弃了我，就好像我不想去似的。那是我最糟糕的生日，直到今天。这就是他一直在强调“这是他最糟糕的生日”这个梗。只是，这些都太、太难听下去了。
You're like, oh, I know, I know.
Well, not to make it worse, but I did ask Matt to pull,
this is from the super fan of the surplus.
And this is a deleted scene.
No, it's not a worst birthday.
It's just about his childhood.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
你会觉得，哦，我懂，我懂。好吧，并不是想让情况更糟，但我确实让马特截取了这一段，这是来自《剩余物资》超级粉丝版的。这是一个被删减的场景。不，这不是关于最糟糕的生日。这只是关于他的童年。哦，天哪。好吧。
Okay, let's listen.
I would like to tell you a little story.
about a boy named...
That doesn't even matter.
Could be any one of you.
And like any other 12-year-old boy,
he wanted a pippy long-stocking doll for Christmas.
But his evil stepfather, Jeff said,
好吧，我们来听听。我想给你们讲一个小故事。关于一个名叫……那甚至不重要。可能是你们中的任何一个人。就像其他任何12岁的男孩一样，他圣诞节想要一个长袜子皮皮娃娃。但是他邪恶的继父杰夫说，
no, you may not have what you want.
You must have a football.
And the boy cried, and he cried, and he cried,
and he held his breath as long as he could,
and he wouldn't eat his dinner.
But you know something?
It turns out that Jeff was right.
Because I already had a G.I. Joe and a Stretch Armstrong, and a Malibu Barbie, and a Major Matt Mason,
不，你不能得到你想要的东西。你必须有一个橄榄球。那个男孩哭了，他哭了，他哭了，他憋气憋到实在憋不住，而且他不肯吃晚饭。但你知道吗？事实证明杰夫是对的。因为我已经有了一个特种部队人偶和一个弹性阿姆斯特朗，和一个马里布芭比，和一个马特·梅森少校，
which technically is enough for a tea party.
So my point is this.
I didn't need what I thought I needed.
What I needed was to learn how to appreciate what I had.
Which in this case was enough dollars to have tea with.
Exactly.
Got it.
Now.
严格来说，这些已经足够开一场茶话会了。所以我的观点是这样的。我不需要我以为我需要的东西。我需要的是学会欣赏我拥有的东西。在这个例子里，就是有足够的娃娃来一起喝茶。完全正确。明白了。现在。
Oh, God.
Jeff. It's always Jeff.
Always Jeff.
Another one like that that I just thought of too
is when Jim says, just make fun of yourself
and then they won't make fun of you after he falls in a lake.
And he's like, actually, it's not the first time I fell into it.
Like, the girls used to throw me in a lake.
哦，天哪。杰夫。总是有杰夫。永远都是杰夫。另一个让我想到类似情节的是，当吉姆说，只要取笑你自己，然后他们就不会取笑你了，这是在他掉进湖里之后。然后他说，其实，这不是我第一次掉进去了。就像，以前女孩子们经常把我扔进湖里。
And when he's telling it and then he's like,
everyone's like starting to get uncomfortable, like,
oh, this is actually kind of a deep-rooted trauma thing.
It's not actually funny.
And then he goes, too far!
He says too far and he has this like frog in his throat.
And he's like, thanks.
Thanks a lot, Jim.
当他在讲这个的时候，然后他发现，大家开始觉得有点不舒服，就像，哦，这其实是一种根深蒂固的创伤。这其实一点也不好笑。然后他说，过头了！他说过头了，喉咙里像卡了只青蛙一样。然后他说，谢谢。多谢了，吉姆。
Thanks for the advice.
It just kills me.
I just can't even deal with that.
And then also I have a couple written down,
except I didn't write them down.
I put them all in voice notes.
So I'm reading all the transcription of my insane ramblings.
So wait, you're rambling into your phone, your favorite one is?
谢谢你的建议。这简直笑死我了。我简直没法面对这个。然后我还写了几个下来，不过我其实没写下来。我都录成语音备忘录了。所以我正在阅读我那些疯狂胡言乱语的文字记录。等等，你在手机里胡言乱语，你最喜欢的是哪一个？
Yeah, because I was trying to like, this is a really hard one for me.
Like this is a hard question for me.
But the last one that I thought of was in weight loss when he's like,
Kelly and I are the only ones who've either pass out or almost pass out, and he does this flapping.
Yes, I know it.
Yes.
And that is so amazing.
It just, oh, God.
对，因为我当时在想，这对我来说真的是一个很难的。就像这对我来说是个很难的问题。但我最后想到的是在《减肥》那一集里，当他说，凯莉和我 是仅有的两个晕倒或差点晕倒的人，然后他做了这个拍打的动作。是的，我知道。是的。这太惊人了。简直是，哦，天哪。
And it's just so clearly just him.
Yes.
And it's so exactly how we feel as people.
Like, it's just like the most like childlike tantrum flap.
Yeah.
That just every time he does that, it makes me laugh out loud.
And then also.
Okay, wait.
而且这显然就是他本人。是的。这简直就是我们作为人的真实感受。就像，这就像是最孩子气的发脾气拍打。是的。他每次做这个动作，都让我忍不住大声笑出来。还有。好吧，等等。
Jerk, are you dreaming?
That one got him.
He's like really...
He's looking really pig-like right now,
just for everyone wondering.
The other one was like, just, I mean,
prison Mike is just the most iconic thing in the world.
And also specifically, I love
混蛋，你在做梦吗？那个戳中他了。他看起来真的……他现在看起来真的很像猪，仅仅为了让大家知道。另一个就像是，我是说，监狱迈克简直是世界上最具标志性的东西。而且特别的是，我喜欢
that John in the background is like kind of breaking,
but my favorite part of him breaking
is I like the idea that it's actually Jim laughing
at what Michael is doing
because one thing
that I've always thought
about the office
is of course
约翰在背景里好像有点笑场了，但我最喜欢他笑场的部分是，我喜欢这种设定：这其实是吉姆在笑迈克在做的事情，因为我一直以来对《办公室》的看法之一就是，当然
the humor at the beginning
of more is like
so dry
and it's like
no one laughs, right?
And Michael is doing
so many things to you
specifically in the first season
一开始那种冷幽默是非常干巴巴的，就好像没有人笑，对吧？迈克在第一季中对你做了很多事情
that is like
you're just like
looking at him deadpan
and not laughing
and I feel like
the one thing
that I've always thought
is throughout the show
就是那种你面无表情地看着他、完全不笑的感觉，而我觉得我一直以来的一个想法就是，在整部剧的播出过程中
the amount of things
that are so ridiculous and so, like, unironically funny,
I would laugh out loud at in real life.
And, like, the fact that Jim is dying, laughing at Michael doing this prison mic thing,
I think is so real.
Because wouldn't you laugh at this guy doing that in front of you?
Like, especially if you're with your friends and, you know, you're not supposed to laugh.
And you're not supposed to laugh.
那些荒谬至极、而且毫无反讽意味的搞笑桥段，如果放在现实生活中，我会直接笑出声来。而且，吉姆居然对迈克搞的这个监狱迈克把戏笑得要死，我觉得这太真实了。因为难道你不会对一个在你面前做这种事的家伙笑吗？尤其是如果你和你的朋友在一起，而且你知道，你本不应该笑。而你又本不应该笑。
And so whenever anyone breaks, I'm like, that is so real.
though, because in real life, somebody doing something as ridiculous as that you would laugh
without even meaning to, even if you're not supposed to. And I love those moments so much.
Anyway, I have to cut myself off because I'm going to keep going. Okay.
What of everything you learn in history class was only half the story? I'm Dr. Hrini-Bot,
host of hidden history. Every Monday, I go where history gets mysterious. Vanished civilizations,
doomsday prophecies, paranormal phenomena, and events that science
Still can't fully explain.
所以每当有人笑场时，我就会想，那太真实了。因为在现实生活中，有人做出这么荒谬的事情，你甚至不需要刻意去想就会笑出来，哪怕你本不该笑。我太喜欢这些时刻了。总之，我得打住我自己了，因为我要说个没完了。好吧。如果历史课上你学到的一切都只是真相的一半呢？我是“隐藏历史”的主持人里尼博特博士。每周一，我都会探访那些历史变得神秘的地方。消逝的文明、末日预言、超自然现象，以及科学至今无法完全解释的事件。
On Hidden History, I treat these moments like open case files.
Not Miss, not superstition, just incomplete explanations waiting for a closer look.
Listen to and follow Hidden History, available now wherever you get your podcast.
Well, we also want to hear about your movie.
Yes, that's coming out.
It's a big deal.
This is amazing.
Okay, so by the time everyone hears this, the movie will be out because it came out on May 8th.
在《隐藏历史》中，我把这些时刻当作未结案的卷宗对待。没有神秘主义，没有迷信，只有等待仔细审视的不完整解释。收听并关注《隐藏历史》，现已在各大播客平台上线。好吧，我们还想听听你的电影。是的，马上就要上映了。这是一件大事。这太棒了。好吧，所以等大家听到这个节目时，电影应该已经上映了，因为它是5月8日上映的。
Yes.
It's hit me hard and soft the tour.
You co-directed it with James Cameron.
In 3D.
It's true.
I mean, I saw the trailer.
I already have tickets.
I can't wait to see it.
是的。这就是“软硬兼施”巡演。你和詹姆斯·卡梅隆共同执导的。3D版的。是真的。我是说，我看过预告片了。我已经买好票了。我等不及要看了。
It's part of my daughter's birthday present.
I'm taking her on a friend.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
We've got a whole moms and daughters crew.
We'll be filling up two different theaters.
Okay.
But yeah, tell us about it.
这是我女儿生日礼物的一部分。我要带她和一个朋友去。是的。哦，天哪。我们有一整个妈妈和女儿的粉丝团。我们要包下两个不同的影厅。好吧。不过，给我们讲讲吧。
It looks so great.
It looks like you're giving people a lot of access, too.
Real behind the scenes.
Yeah, that was like not planned and kind of came about naturally.
And I at first was very like, no, I don't want to do that.
Because I was filmed from when I was 15 to when I was 18 for this documentary that was made, which was an amazing experience.
But like, a lot of my life was filmed.
And I kind of have this like, oh, no, I'm good.
看起来太棒了。看起来你也向大家展示了很多幕后内容。真实的幕后花絮。是的，那其实不是计划好的，算是自然而然发生的。一开始我很抗拒，心想“不，我不想那样”。因为在这部纪录片拍摄期间，我从15岁到18岁一直被摄像机对着，那是一段美妙的经历。但是，我的生活很大一部分都被拍进去了。我当时心里有一种“哦不，我挺好的”的感觉。
Like, I don't know if I, you know.
And so when it came about, I was like, oh, I would love to capture this show.
First of all, it's my favorite show I've ever created, and I had such an amazing time on the tour, and just in general, that show is like my best work.
Like, I just feel like you in that scene.
Like, I'm like, yeah, you know what?
I will agree.
This is my best work.
I feel very proud.
就好像，我不知道我是不是，你知道的。所以当这件事提上日程时，首先，这是我创作过最喜欢的节目，我在巡演中度过了非常美妙的时光，总的来说，那个节目就是我最好的作品。我就感觉自己像你在那个场景里一样。我就想，好吧，你知道吗？我同意。这就是我最好的作品。我感到非常自豪。
So I felt really excited about that, but at first I was like, I don't want to do any behind-the-scenes stuff.
I don't want to make it like a documentary of any kind because I don't want to share too much.
And honestly, Jim, James Scarrant, Jim.
Jim.
He agreed, by the way.
But then when we were kind of moving through it, he was like, what if we just like talked and filmed it?
And I was kind of like, I don't know.
And it just came so naturally.
所以我对此感到非常兴奋，但一开始我觉得我不想做任何幕后花絮。我不想把它拍成任何形式的纪录片，因为我不想分享太多。说实话，吉姆，詹姆斯·斯卡兰特，吉姆。吉姆。顺便说一句，他同意了。但后来在我们推进的过程中，他说，如果我们只是边聊天边拍呢？我当时有点拿不定主意。但这一切发生得太自然了。
And also beyond being naturally happening, it was also like I saw the importance of it.
And I thought, you know what?
this is the reality of me and my show.
And it's like, yeah, if we're going to be showing this show that I've worked so hard on,
let's show the experience of doing that and what is my day like leading up to it.
And also, like, the fans haven't seen that in a while.
And I thought that it would be really fun for them too.
And also in 3D, I mean, I would have loved to have seen my favorite artist when I was young in 3D
而且除了自然发生之外，我也看到了它的重要性。我想，你知道吗？这就是我和我的节目的真实状态。这就好比，是的，既然我们要展示这个我付出如此大努力的节目，那就把创作的过程展示出来，我为之准备的一天是怎样的。而且，粉丝们已经很久没有看过这些了。我觉得这对他们来说也会非常有趣。还有3D格式的，我是说，我年轻时要是能以3D形式看到我最喜欢的艺术家，我会非常乐意
because I could have felt like I was there.
and I was in front of them.
And it's been a really intense and long and grueling process
of making it and editing it and working on every aspect of it.
But it's now I can feel, I feel like really,
because I feel really good about it.
And I think it's really good.
And I'm really, really excited.
因为我会感觉自己就在现场。我就在他们面前。这是一个非常激烈、漫长且折磨人的过程，包括制作、剪辑以及处理它的每一个方面。但现在我能感受到，我真的感觉很好，因为我对它感觉真的很好。而且我觉得它真的很棒。我真的、真的非常兴奋。
I can't wait.
I'm really excited.
You know, there's this great quote that has something to do with like,
one of the greatest gifts as an artist that you can give other artists
is to show your brush strokes.
Yeah.
because we so often just put out, like, you just see the final thing.
And so I feel like with this movie, we're going to get to see some of the brushstrokes.
我等不及了。我真的很兴奋。你知道，有一句很棒的名言大意是，作为艺术家你能给予其他艺术家最伟大的礼物之一，就是展示你的笔触。是的。因为我们通常只把成品展示出来，你只能看到最后的结果。所以我觉得通过这部电影，我们将有机会看到一些笔触。
We're going to see how the whole thing comes together.
Yeah.
My daughter just admires you so much.
And I love that she's going to see someone that she idolizes, like, doing all the work to get to the big moment on stage.
Right.
And then also.
Yeah, that's true.
I didn't even think of that.
我们将看到整个作品是如何凝聚在一起的。是的。我女儿太崇拜你了。我很高兴她能看到一个她崇拜的人，为了达到舞台上的高光时刻而付出所有的努力。没错。然后还有。是的，确实如此。我甚至都没想到这一点。
It's just really cool, you know?
It's like a really valuable gift.
that you're giving.
Yeah.
So thank you.
I mean, I always love the final product.
The process is what always just like tugs at my heartstrings because you see how much work it really is.
And it's so important to see the work that you put into something.
这真的很酷，你知道吗？就像是一份非常宝贵的礼物，你正在给予大家。是的。所以谢谢你。我是说，我总是喜欢最终的产品。但这个过程才是我内心最触动的地方，因为你能看到它背后真正付出了多少工作。看到你为某件事付出的努力是如此重要。
It's really true.
Yeah.
That's really true.
I hadn't really thought about that.
And it's really true because I think like it's so easy to see a final product and be like, well, that it was perfect from the start.
And it just wasn't.
And also, like, you know, even though this movie, we didn't.
until I was already way into the tour.
这千真万确。是的。这绝对是真的。我之前没怎么想过这一点。这确实是真的，因为我觉得人们很容易看到一个最终的成品，然后就会想，哦，它从一开始就是完美的。但它其实并不是。而且，你知道的，尽管这部电影，我们直到巡演已经进行到很后面的时候才开始。
And, you know, I had been doing the show for a while.
And it was kind of perfect at that point in terms of, like, process.
But we had filmed, like, we had, just to have, we'd filmed a little bit of the beginning
of the tour.
And also specifically, like, the night before, and it's in the movie somewhat, but the
night before we started filming, I sprained my ankle, which I hadn't done in six years.
I used to do all the time, and literally I was in Manchester to film the movie.
I had this meeting with Jim.
而且，你知道的，我已经演出一段时间了。就过程而言，那个时候已经算是挺完美的了。但我们确实拍过，我们只是为了以防万一，拍了巡演开始的一小部分。特别是在开拍前的那天晚上——这在电影里也有所体现——就在我们开始拍摄的前一晚，我扭伤了脚踝，这已经六年没发生过了。我以前经常扭伤，而当时我正好在曼彻斯特准备拍电影。我和吉姆开完会，
I went to my hotel, and I immediately sprained mangled by stepping out onto my balcony, which was a two-inch drop.
You're so athletic in your concerts, but it was like stepping on the balcony.
Yes, that's what did it.
And so I, the next day started one of many, many shows in a row being filmed in 3D with a sprained ankle.
And I was like, you know what?
This gives me a challenge.
I love a challenge.
I'm going to do it.
回到了酒店，结果一走出阳台就立刻把脚踝给扭了，那个阳台只有两寸高。你在演唱会上那么有活力，结果却是因为踩上阳台。是的，就是那个导致了受伤。所以第二天，我带着扭伤的脚踝，开始了一场接一场的3D拍摄演出。我当时就想，你知道吗？这给我出了个挑战。我喜欢挑战。我要把它完成。
I'm going to, you know, and I think like really what the movie is about, aside from, you know, the fact that this tour and this show is so special for me and I want everyone to see it and the fact that the tour ended and not everyone in the entire world got to watch it is I feel so grateful and lucky that people who didn't get to come are going to get to see it and feel like they were there.
also people who did get to see it and want to relive it and specifically, selfishly, that I will forever get to watch this and have it.
Yes.
It's so special, I think, to have any kind of visual or oral history of something that meant a lot to you.
And we have that with our podcast.
We think about that all the time.
Yeah.
Yeah, we've said now, we've gotten on record, every memory and story, minus the ones we're saving for office ladies,
我要，你知道的，而且我觉得这部电影真正讲的是，除了（你知道的）这次巡演和这个节目对我的意义极其重大、我希望所有人都能看到它，以及巡演结束了并非全世界所有人都能观看到这些之外——我感到非常感激和幸运，那些没能来到现场的人将能够看到它并感觉自己仿佛身临其境。还有那些曾经观看过并想要重温的人，以及极其自私地说，我将能够永远观看并拥有这份影像。是的。我认为拥有对你意义重大的事物的任何形式的视觉或口述历史都是非常特别的。我们的播客也是如此。我们一直都在这样想。是的。是的，我们现在已经把每一段记忆和故事都记录在案了，除了那些我们要留给“办公室女士”播客的之外。
to the ground.
Yeah.
We have them out there now.
Girl, we're all ready for that one.
We are all ready for that.
But it's like in the,
literally in the office,
when Phyllis says, like,
全部抖搂出去了。是的。我们现在都把它们公之于众了。姑娘，我们都准备好了。我们都准备好了。但这就像在《办公室》里，菲利斯说的那样，
I worked here for this long
and I never wrote anything down.
You know, we all think like,
oh, I'll remember that forever.
And you just won't.
And like, if it's filmed,
and like, you guys,
like, this is recorded forever.
我在这里工作了这么久，却从来没有写下过任何东西。你知道的，我们都会觉得，哦，我会永远记住那个。但你其实根本记不住。如果被拍下来了，就像你们这样，这被永远记录了下来。
Like, you're going to have this forever to listen to
to and you have the office forever to watch.
Like, it's just such a gift.
And I feel, honestly, before Jim reached out to us, me, through my mother, he sent an email to my mom.
Literally, that's how it happened.
Amazing.
I was like, I didn't have any plans to film the show because I wasn't going to make a concert film of any kind.
And I was already feeling like, damn, that sucks.
就像，你们将永远拥有这个音频可以回听，而且你们也拥有《办公室》可以永远观看。这真是一份巨大的礼物。老实说，在吉姆通过我妈妈联系我们之前，他给我妈妈发了一封电子邮件。真的，事情就是这样发生的。太神奇了。我当时想，我根本没有计划拍摄这个演出，因为我本来没打算制作任何形式的演唱会电影。我当时已经有一种“天哪，太糟了”的感觉。
Like, this is such an important show to me.
And no one's ever going to be able to, like, watch it.
And the movie really is about the fans.
Like the real truth is that it's all about the fans and my feeling of devotion to them and their feeling of that with me and our love.
And like, honestly, similar to the office.
It's like, what am I without my fans, you know?
And it's like, what is the office without the fans?
It's just, it's all this one big.
就像，这是一个对我如此重要的节目。而没有人能够观看到它。这部电影其实是关于粉丝的。真实的真相是，这一切都是为了粉丝，以及我对他们的那种奉献感、他们与我之间的那种情感以及我们的爱。说实话，这和《办公室》很像。这就好比，如果没有粉丝，我算什么，你知道吗？这就好比，如果没有粉丝，《办公室》算什么？这一切都是一个整体。
Absolutely, the community.
The community of it.
And that's my favorite thing in the world.
I wouldn't do any of this if it weren't for that, you know?
It's a really cool thing.
The openness and the like human to human thing that happens, like when we meet someone and they are telling us how much the office means to them, that is such a gift to me that I get to be part of this thing that brought that other person, this joy or whatever.
So it's like it's such a really cool connection.
It's really cool.
绝对的，这就是社群。它的社群感。这是我世上最喜欢的东西。如果不是因为这个，我根本不会做这一切，你知道吗？这真是一件很酷的事情。那种开放性以及人与人之间的连结，就像我们遇到某个人，他们告诉我们《办公室》对他们有多么重要，对我来说这真是一份厚礼，我能成为这个带给另一个人快乐或其他感受的事物的一部分。所以这真的是一种非常酷的连结。真的很酷。
And like, you know, this is like, I know, like an intense subject.
but like what you were saying about sharing your process.
That made me think of like your health journey, Jenna,
and how what you said on the podcast about like,
this is a really intense, scary thing to be going through.
And you have totally the right to be like,
I'm never speaking about it.
I'm never talking about it.
而且，你知道的，这就像是一个深刻的话题，但我知道，就像你刚才说的关于分享你的心路历程。这让我想到了你的健康之旅，珍娜，以及你在播客中所说的，这是一件非常沉重、可怕的事情。你有完全的权利说，我绝不谈论这件事。我永远不会提起它。
Please don't ask me about it.
And instead, because you have said on this podcast,
about how like sharing your experience might help other people and other people who are experiencing
this. And that is such an amazing gift. And the amount of people that I think you sharing your
health journey with like changed their lives and made them feel seen and like they're not alone. And
that's just really special. And you don't have to do that yet you do. And I think like that's
obviously like completely a different thing than the stupid little movie I'm doing.
But it just made me think of that.
请不要问我关于这个的事。而相反地，因为你在播客中说过，分享你的经历可能会帮助到其他人，以及其他正在经历这一切的人。这真是一份无比美妙的礼物。而且我认为你分享健康之旅改变了多少人的生活，让他们感到自己被看见、并不孤单。这真的非常特别。你本不必这样做，但你还是做了。我觉得这显然和那个愚蠢的小电影完全是两码事。但这让我想到了这一点。
And I just wanted to verbalize to you, like, you don't owe anyone anything.
And yet, you're so giving.
And it's just so magical.
And, like, sharing your story with people just to help them is so selfless and so kind.
And, yeah, I just had to say that.
Well, thank you.
You know, it is a fine line.
It's like there's always that question of how much do I share and how much do I keep for
我只是想对你直抒胸臆，你并不欠任何人任何东西。然而，你却如此慷慨大方。这简直太神奇了。而且，仅仅为了帮助他人而与大家分享你的故事，是如此无私和善良。是的，我不得不说出这些。好吧，谢谢你。你知道，这确实是一条微妙的界限。这就像总会有这样一个问题：我应该分享多少，又该为自己保留多少？
myself. Sometimes, you know, when I start sharing about breast cancer, I have to think about
breast cancer. And I'm pretty excited to not think about it. So there's that. But the thing is,
is that any time I've had a person tell me that they got checked because they heard my story
or they found something early enough to do something about it because they got checked because
they heard my story, it means so much to me. Like, it means so much to me. But yet, even still,
I do pick my moments. And I think that it's okay to pick your moments of access. Like,
you don't have to give everything. But, you know, there's a balance there. And I think that's as an
artist, I think we're always trying to find that balance, which is like, how much do I have to
有时候，你知道的，当我开始分享关于乳腺癌的事情时，我就不得不去想乳腺癌。而我其实挺想不去想它的。所以就是这样。但关键是，每当有人告诉我，他们因为听到我的故事而去做了检查，或者因为听到我的故事而去检查从而足够早地发现问题并采取了行动，这对我的意义太重大了。真的，意义非凡。但即便如此，我还是会挑选时机。我觉得挑选展示自己的时机是没有问题的。你不需要倾其所有。但是，这其中存在一个平衡。我觉得作为艺术家，我们总是在努力寻找那种平衡，那就是——我有多少要……
keep for myself? Also, in order to do my art, I don't know about you. But, like,
Like, there's a certain amount of, like, process that I get into superstitious thinking.
And if I share too much, then it doesn't work.
Yeah.
And also, like, again, not that just what you were saying made me think of how much I look up to you and how much everyone looks up to you.
And I'm in no way trying to compare it the two or your experience and your journey with anything in the entire world.
Because it's like.
But you're talking about sharing.
留给自己？而且，为了创作艺术，我不知道你怎么样。但是，感觉，感觉，有那么一瞬间，我会陷入迷信的思维。如果我分享得太多，它就不起作用了。是的。而且还有，再次强调，并不是说你刚才说的话让我想到我多么敬仰你，以及所有人多么敬仰你。我绝不是想把这两者，或者你和你的经历、你的旅程，与世界上任何事情进行比较。因为就像是。但你谈论的是分享。
But I'm just talking about in general.
No, when you get.
Sharing is so.
Sharing.
you put yourself out there.
You're vulnerable.
Every time you share no matter what it is, you're sharing.
但我只是泛泛而谈。不，当你开始。分享太重要了。分享。分享。你把自己展现出来。你很脆弱。每次你分享，无论是什么内容，你就是在分享。
And in life, whether you're like a junior in high school and you decide to share your essay in front of the class or you're, I don't know, a nurse at the hospital and you share like the crocheted sweater you made.
I don't know.
Anyway, this is like a Michael Scott analogy.
I am turning into Michael Scott we've discovered.
But I do think every time you share as a person, you're stepping out there.
Rewarded.
Yeah. And it's like, it's just, we must not forget that sharing saves lives.
Like, it saves lives. And like, it's just, it's easy to be like, uh, no, no. And you know what?
而在生活中，无论你是一个高中的高三学生，决定在全班面前分享你的短文，还是你，我不知道，医院里的一名护士，分享你织的钩针毛衣。我不知道。总之，这就像迈克·斯科特（Michael Scott）的比喻。我们发现我正在变成迈克·斯科特。但我确实认为，作为一个人，每一次你分享，你都是在迈进未知的领域。得到回报。是的。而且，这就像，我们绝不能忘记分享能拯救生命。真的，它能拯救生命。而且，这就像，人们很容易说，呃，不，不。你知道吗？
You don't have to also. You don't ever have to. You don't have to. You get to decide. And the one thing I will say, you know, about the office and about your concerts and going to concerts like that.
My daughter went to this concert with her friends and saw it. And there is a shared joy. And that's amazing.
Yeah. Like to share joy with someone, like that should be our goal, right? Is to share joy. And I know your movie's going to do that for people.
And it's going to bring it to people who didn't get a chance to see it. I know. That to me is like the most important thing, you know? And I'm just really excited. And also I'm just, I'm excited again, like what you said, like for people to like go have that experience together and like go with their friends and make friends. And, and.
have this memory and go with their families.
And, you know, it's just like thinking about that is really, really special.
Anyway, sorry, Jenna, to bring that stuff up, but I just wanted to say that I'm, I feel very
inspired by you and very tender towards you.
你其实也不必这么做。你永远都不必这么做。你不一定要分享。你可以自己决定。我要说的一件事是，你知道的，关于《办公室》以及你的演唱会和去看那样的演唱会。我女儿和她的朋友们去看了这场演唱会。那种快乐是共享的。这太棒了。是的。就像与某人分享快乐，这应该是我们的目标，对吧？就是分享快乐。我知道你的电影会带给人们这种体验。它会把它带给那些没有机会看到它的人。我知道。对我来说，这才是最重要的事情，你知道吗？我真的超级兴奋。而且我也，我再次感到兴奋，就像你所说的那样，人们可以一起去拥有那种体验，和朋友们一起去，结交朋友，然后。留下这段记忆，和家人一起去。而且，你知道，光是想想这些就真的非常、非常特别。总之，对不起，珍娜（Jenna），把这些话题挑起来，但我只是想说，我感到非常受你的启发，对你充满了温柔的爱意。
Well, I actually appreciate you saying it.
It was well-timed because I just agreed to do a little bit of like a public service campaign,
and I was feeling a little nervous about it.
Wow.
That's a lot.
So thank you because, you know, I was nervous.
So I'm going to go into this campaign and I'm going to be fired up.
Oh my gosh.
嗯，其实我很感激你说这些。时机正好，因为我刚刚答应做一个类似公益广告的项目，我当时对此感觉有点紧张。哇。这可不简单。所以谢谢你，因为，你知道的，我很紧张。所以我要去参加这个活动，而且我会充满斗志。哦天哪。
Thanks to you.
Oh, God.
I'm glad.
You're amazing.
I'm...
Aw.
Everyone loves you.
Anyway.
多亏了你。哦，天哪。我很高兴。你太棒了。我……啊。每个人都爱你。总之。
All right.
Well, listen.
We have one more thing planned before you leave, which is that you have requested.
Yes, I have.
To do an office quiz.
With your friend Jack.
With my friend Jack.
Okay.
好吧。听着。在你离开之前，我们还计划了一件事，那就是你要求的。是的，我要求了。做一次办公室问答测验。和你的朋友杰克一起。和我的朋友杰克一起。好的。
So let me explain really quick.
So my best friend, Alex, Wolf, he's an incredible actor.
He's wonderful.
And Alex, he has...
has another very best friend, and it's Jack Metzger, and he happens to be the J in the band
AJR, if you've heard of them. Anyway, I met him through Alex, and like at some point a couple
years ago, we met and we were around each other, and I knew he was out, my best friend's other
best friend who lived in New York, and I was like, oh, you're the other best friend, oh,
那我简单解释一下。我最好的朋友，亚历克斯·沃尔夫（Alex Wolf），他是一个不可思议的演员。他太棒了。而亚历克斯，他有……还有另一个最好的朋友，那就是杰克·梅茨格（Jack Metzger），他恰好是乐队AJR里的那个“J”，如果你听说过他们的话。总之，我是通过亚历克斯认识他的，在几年前的某个时候，我们见面了，经常在一起，我知道他是在外地，我最好朋友的另一个住在纽约的好朋友，当时我就想，哦，你就是那个“另一个最好的朋友”，哦，
you know, and then they were like, well, actually Jack knows the office like better than anyone
in the world. And I was like, oh, hmm, interesting.
because no, he doesn't.
And I remember immediately having this feeling of like,
the hell, no, he doesn't.
And actually, instead of it making me like,
like we started talking about it,
and I felt seen for the first time in my way.
你知道的，然后他们就说，嗯，其实杰克比世界上任何人都更了解《办公室》。然后我就想，哦，嗯，有意思。因为，才没有呢。我记得当时立刻有了一种感觉，觉得，见鬼，才没有呢。事实上，这并没有让我反感——我们开始聊起这个，我第一次以这种方式感到了被理解。
I was like, oh my God,
I've never met anyone who loves the office the way I do
until I met Jack.
And so we immediately became Best Budds.
And now he's like one of my favorite people in the world.
And anyway, all we do,
We have a group chat called Office Trivia.
He loves the Office as much as me and almost is as good as I am with the trivia.
我就想，天哪，在遇到杰克之前，我从没见过任何人像我一样热爱《办公室》。所以我们立刻成了死党。现在他成了我世界上最喜欢的人之一。总之，我们所做的一切，我们有一个叫“办公室冷知识”的群聊。他对《办公室》的热爱和我一样多，冷知识水平几乎也和我一样好。
Just the thing.
On that note, we're going to take a break.
And when we come back, we're going to have Jack and we're going to do Trivia.
Office trivia.
Okay.
Jack, like our like connection about this show has been life changing and.
I literally love you so much, seriously.
就是这样。说到这，我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将邀请杰克，我们要进行知识问答。办公室冷知识。好吧。好吧。杰克，我们对这部剧的这种联系可以说是改变了生活，而且。我真的超级超级爱你，说真的。
And so anyway, he's very nervous.
He wouldn't say it, but he's very nervous.
And he's trying to act cool, but he's really nervous.
How many times have you seen it?
Have you watched it a lot?
Honestly, I would say probably 20 times through.
Okay.
So do you have a favorite season or?
所以无论如何，他非常紧张。他不会说出来，但他真的很紧张。他试图装酷，但他真的很紧张。你看过多少遍了？你看了很多遍吗？老实说，我大概看了20遍吧。好的。那你最喜欢哪一季，还是？
I'm probably going to go with season two.
Season two.
Respectable.
I like it.
Yep, season two.
I used to watch you when it first came on, first season on TV.
Oh, that's amazing.
Appointment television days.
我可能会选第二季。第二季。可以接受。我喜欢。是的，第二季。当它刚开播时，我还在电视上看第一季。哦，太棒了。那是黄金时段追剧的年代。
Yeah.
Must see TV Thursdays.
All right.
Well, let's get this trivia going.
We're going to start with this.
It's the official office trivia board game.
It says, are you a true Dunderhead?
是的。是的。周四必看电视节目。好吧。好了，我们开始这个知识问答吧。我们从这个开始。这是官方的《办公室》知识问答桌游。上面写着，你是个真正的笨蛋吗？
Whoa.
Dunderhead.
Let's find out.
I'm going to pick five from this deck randomly.
Here we go.
And then Jenna has a special surprise quiz.
Oh, my God.
But we're going to do.
哇。笨蛋。让我们拭目以待。我将从这副牌里随机抽五张。我们开始吧。然后珍娜有一个特别的惊喜测验。哦，天哪。但我们要进行的是。
Look at that.
We go. Official the office trivia game.
I'm scared.
Who told Michael to, quote, start over after Michael called him an idiot?
Darrell.
Oh, Darrell.
Oh, my gosh, right away.
Okay.
看这个。我们开始。官方的《办公室》问答游戏。我好害怕。谁让迈克尔在迈克尔叫他笨蛋后“重新开始”？达瑞尔（Darrell）。哦，达瑞尔。哦，天哪，一下子就答出来了。好的。
Who was the secretary of Knights of the Night?
Dwight.
Yes, softball.
Okay, that's like too easy.
It was confusing almost.
Whom did Dwight want to give a post-apocalypse, quote,
knapsack filled with canned goods, chainsaw, gasoline?
DeAngelo.
“黑夜骑士”的秘书是谁？德怀特（Dwight）。是的，太简单了。好吧，这简直太简单了。甚至有点让人困惑。德怀特想给谁一个装满罐头食品、电锯、汽油的末日生存“背包”？迪安杰洛（DeAngelo）。
Yes, DiAngelo.
I couldn't even process what you're saying.
Oh my gosh, you got that so quick.
Okay.
Who became the receptionist and loved it while most of the office was in Florida?
Annie.
Yeah.
Okay.
是的，迪安杰洛。我甚至都还没反应过来你在说什么。哦天哪，你答得太快了。好的。当办公室大部分人都在佛罗里达时，谁成了前台接待员并乐在其中？安妮（Annie）。是的。好的。
Is that five?
That's four.
Here we go.
Who told Angela that the only premature baby in the room was the one her baby eight?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
What was the baby this baby eight?
Oscar.
这是第五个吗？这是第四个。我们开始。谁对安吉拉说，房间里唯一早产的婴儿就是她孩子吃掉的那只？哦。哦，哦。这个婴儿吃掉的是什么婴儿？奥斯卡（Oscar）。
Yeah.
God, I couldn't.
I haven't seen that episode in a while.
Okay.
You guys are five for five together.
of the official office trivia game.
But Jenna, are you ready to razzle-dazzle?
Okay, guys, we received an email
是的。天哪，我甚至都记不清了。我好久没看那一集了。好的。你们俩合作五题全对。官方《办公室》问答游戏的题目。但是珍娜，你准备好大显身手了吗？好的，各位，我们收到了一封电子邮件。
Oh, God.
Billy, that said you had requested, quote,
the hardest trivia we could think of.
Why?
We had a feeling that this board game
would be too easy.
So we asked one of the National Office Trivia Tournament winners
to write some questions for you both.
哦，天哪。比利，信里说你要求来点“我们能想到的最难的问答”。为什么？我们有一种预感，这个桌游会太简单了。所以我们请了全国《办公室》知识问答锦标赛的冠军之一为你们俩写了一些问题。
Okay.
This is my friend Will Allen,
who competes in the next year.
National Online Office Trivia Tournament with his team,
Who's Your Worm Guy?
At its peak, this competition was between over 700 teams from around the country.
His team won twice and placed in the top 10 over a dozen times.
So this is his pedigree, okay?
好的。这是我的朋友威尔·艾伦（Will Allen），他和他的团队“谁是你的蠕虫男”（Who's Your Worm Guy?）一起参加了下一届全国在线《办公室》知识问答锦标赛。在巅峰时期，这项比赛吸引了来自全国各地的700多支队伍。他的团队赢了两次，十多次进入前10名。这就是他的履历，好吗？
No pressure.
He says, quote, this is a very difficult quiz.
The easiest questions of this quiz would be final round questions in a hard office trivia tournament.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing? What are you doing?
Okay.
Question number one.
There are 18 toppings that make up the works.
没有压力。他说，“这是一份非常困难的测验。这份测验中最简单的题目，也是一场艰难的办公室问答锦标赛中决赛轮的水平。”哦，天哪。你在干什么？你在干什么？好的。问题一。制作“全套”需要18种配料。
God, damn it.
I knew this was going to happen.
Okay.
How many can you name?
All right.
Caramel drizzle, cotton candy bits.
Those, I'm like,
操，该死的。我就知道会这样。我就知道会这样。好的。你能说出几种？好吧。焦糖细雨酱、棉花糖碎。那些，我在想，
is there white chocolate chips?
There is not white chocolate chips.
Chocolate chips?
Failing already.
Is chocolate chips even in there?
Yes.
You have cotton candy bits, chocolate chip.
Okay, wait.
有白巧克力豆吗？没有白巧克力豆。巧克力豆？已经开始失分了。里面到底有没有巧克力豆？有的。你有棉花糖碎，巧克力豆。好吧，等等。
Chocolate chip.
Will said for a mild amount of respect, please name five.
Okay.
You got this.
I may give you a hint.
You have danced around a few of the words.
Chocolate.
巧克力豆。威尔说出于对游戏微弱的尊重，请说出五个。好的。你能行的。我可能会给你个提示。你们刚才在某些词的边缘反复横跳。巧克力。巧克力。
Yes.
Chocolate.
White chocolate.
Yes.
Oh, okay.
Caramel drizzle.
巧克力。是的。是的。巧克力。白巧克力。是的。哦，好吧。焦糖细雨酱。
Cotton candy bits.
Caramel.
Wait.
Caramel dip.
Thank you.
What the hell?
Wait, is there is a drizzle?
There is a drizzle.
棉花糖碎。焦糖。等等。焦糖蘸酱。谢谢。搞什么鬼？等等，有细雨酱吗？有的，有细雨酱。
I'm hearing the jizzle.
You definitely have named four.
Yes.
You have to name one more to get the point.
有细雨酱。有细雨酱。有细雨酱。有细雨酱。我听到细雨酱了。你们绝对已经说出了四个。是的。你还得说出一个才能得分。
Sprinkles, no?
Sprinkles, yes.
Sprinkles is one.
Okay, so you got five.
Do you want to hear it?
We have the audio.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, wait.
糖屑，对吧？糖屑，是的。糖屑是一个。好的，所以你们得了五个。你想听原声吗？不，不，不，不。好吧，等等。
Are you trying to get more?
I think five is respectable.
Angela?
I need silence.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Is there cinnamon sugar?
Yes.
你们还想答更多吗？我觉得五个已经很体面了。安吉拉？我需要安静。好吧，好吧。等等。有肉桂糖吗？是的。
Okay.
Cinnamon sugar.
That's my favorite.
Cinnamon sugar is really good on a pretzel.
Billy, are you attempting to go for all of them?
How many are there?
There's 18.
好的。肉桂糖。好的。那是我的最爱。肉桂糖撒在软 pretzel 上真的很好吃。比利，你打算把所有的都答出来吗？到底有多少种？有18种。
Are there nuts?
Yes, nuts is one.
Oh, nuts.
There's no powdered sugar, is there?
Yes.
Yes, there is.
That's the last one.
I think that is the last one.
有坚果吗？是的，坚果是一种。哦，坚果。没有糖粉吧？有的。是的，有。那是最后一个。我想那是最后一个。
And powdered sugar, remember?
Yeah.
Yep, that is.
Okay.
You one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
It's pretty good.
I'm going to play the audio clip.
Here it is, everybody.
还有糖粉，记得吗？是的。没错了，就是那个。好的。你有一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八、九、十个。挺不错的。我要播放音频片段了。大家听好了。
Hi, please tell me you have a sweet pretzel left.
We do.
Thank God.
And we have 18 different toppings.
We have sweet glaze, cinnamon sugar, chocolate, white chocolate, fudge, M&Ms, caramel dip, mint chip, chocolate chip, marshmallows, nuts, toffee nuts, coconut, coconut, peanut, peanut, peanut, butter, drizzle, Oreo, sprinkles, cotton candy bits, and powdered sugar.
Is there any way that you could do all, all of them?
The works, you got it.
All right.
嗨，请告诉我你们还剩甜味软 pretzel。我们有。谢天谢地。我们有18种不同的配料。有甜糖衣、肉桂糖、巧克力、白巧克力、热 fudge 酱、M&M 豆、焦糖蘸酱、薄荷巧克力豆、巧克力豆、棉花糖、坚果、太妃坚果、椰子、椰子、花生、花生、花生酱细雨酱、奥利奥、糖屑、棉花糖碎和糖粉。你们有没有办法把所有的、所有的都做出来？“全套”，没问题。好的。
Thank you.
Peanut butter drizzle?
Peanut butter drizzle.
It works. You got it.
All right.
Do you want me to continue with this quiz?
Okay.
Question number two.
谢谢。花生酱细雨酱？花生酱细雨酱。可以。没问题。好的。要我继续这个测验吗？好的。问题二。
Can you name all of the candy bars that Michael references in his business school lecture?
Payday.
Yes.
$100 grand.
Snickers?
Yes.
I'm going to let him do this one.
你能说出迈克尔在商学院讲座中提到的所有糖果棒吗？Payday。是的。100 grand。是的。士力架（Snickers）？是的。我让他来答这个。
There's one more.
You know it really, right?
Yeah.
Wait.
There's one more.
Who's or what's it?
No, no.
You're so close.
还有一个。你其实知道的，对吧？是的。等等。还有一个。叫什么来着？不，不。你们太接近了。
A thing I'm a jig.
What can I call it?
It's it.
Watch your call it.
What you call it.
You got it.
Okay.
那个小玩意。我该怎么叫它？就是它。你叫它什么。What you call it（随便叫什么）。你答对了。你答对了。好的。
When Creed is the interim manager, he calls a meeting where he splits the office into two groups for team building.
Elroy.
Which Dundermifflin employee is somehow listed in both groups and which person named does not actually work there.
Okay.
Elroy.
That's correct.
Doesn't exist.
当克里德（Creed）担任临时经理时，他召开了一次会议，把办公室分成两组来进行团队建设。埃尔罗伊（Elroy）。哪位邓德米福林（Dundermifflin）的员工不知为何被列入了两个小组，哪一个被点名的人实际上并不在那里？好的。埃尔罗伊。埃尔罗伊。答对了。根本不存在。
But there's one person who's listed in both groups.
So he names Phyllis.
That's it.
Oh.
Phyllis and Elroy.
Because he says Phyllis and Elroy.
So that's the answer.
但有一个人被列入了两个小组。所以他点到了菲利斯（Phyllis）。就是这个。就是这个。哦。菲利斯和埃尔罗伊。因为他说的是菲利斯和埃尔罗伊。所以这就是答案。
I did not know about it.
Okay.
Do you want more?
Yes.
Okay.
I want everything.
And then we can do a speed round of the normal game.
Okay.
我之前不知道这个。好的。还要更多吗？是的。好的。我全都要。然后我们可以进行正常游戏的快问快答环节。好的。
And get every single question and then feel a little better about ourselves.
I like that.
When Pam and Andy are stuck working together,
they visit an office park to attempt some in-person business acquisitions.
I don't know how you would know this, but what company conducts business in Sweet 202?
My gosh.
Dean Trophies Sweet 202.
Oh, wait.
把每个问题都答对，然后对我们自己感觉好一点。我喜欢这样。当潘（Pam）和安迪（Andy）被困在一起工作时，他们拜访了一个办公园区，试图进行一些面对面的业务收购。我不知道你们怎么会知道这个，但哪家公司在202室开展业务？天哪。迪恩奖杯（Dean Trophies），202室。哦，等等。
Sherman Bines and Rock.
Yes.
Sherman Blines and Rocks.
Sherman Blinds and Rock Sweet 202.
You wouldn't have got it if we didn't sing it.
That was so good.
That was great.
And then there's like a Dean Trophy's Sweet 100 and Doodily Doe or something like that.
谢尔曼百叶窗和罗克（Sherman Bines and Rock）。是的。谢尔曼百叶窗和罗克。谢尔曼百叶窗和罗克，202室。如果我们不唱出来，你根本猜不到。太棒了。太棒了。然后好像还有一个迪恩奖杯100室和迪迪多（Doodily Doe）之类的。
Yeah.
Doodle do.
That sounds like Andy.
And then sweet, food.
Four of one.
Yeah.
Besides the United States
where Dwight would originally steal
是的。Doodle do。听起来像安迪会说的话。然后还有，食物。第四个。是的。除了德怀特原本要偷蒂芙尼水晶灯的美国之外，
the Tiffany Chandelier,
what are the four other countries
involved in this heist?
Okay.
Canada is one, right?
Mexico?
Yeah.
France, yes.
参与这次抢劫的另外四个国家是什么？好的。加拿大是一个，对吧？墨西哥？是的。法国，是的。
France.
You only need one more.
Is it somewhere random?
No, it's somewhere that might be
part of Dwight's family of origin.
Oh, that's a huge hint.
Germany?
Yes.
法国。你只需要再猜一个。是在某个随机的地方吗？不，是在可能是德怀特祖籍所在地的地方。哦，这是一个巨大的提示。德国？是的。
Huck.
Oh, wow.
Jenna gave me that one.
What is my perfect crime?
I break into Tiffany's in midnight.
Do I go for the vault?
No, I go for the chandelier.
It's priceless.
哈哈。哦，哇。珍娜给了我这个提示。我的完美犯罪是什么？我在午夜闯入蒂芙尼（Tiffany’s）。我是去拿金库吗？不，我是去拿水晶灯。它无价之宝。
As I'm taking it down, a woman catches me.
She tells me to stop.
It's her father's business.
She's Tiffany.
We make love all night.
In the morning, the cops come, and I escape in one of their uniforms.
I tell her to meet me in Mexico, but I go to Canada.
I don't trust her.
当我把它取下来时，一个女人抓住了我。她叫我住手。这是她父亲的生意。她就是蒂芙尼。我们整晚做爱。到了早上，警察来了，我穿着他们的制服逃跑了。我告诉她在墨西哥等我，但我去了加拿大。我不信任她。
Besides, I like the cold.
30 years later, I get a postcard.
I have a son.
And he's the chief of police.
This is where the story gets interesting.
I tell Tiffany to meet me in Paris by the Trocadero.
She's been waiting for me all these years.
She's never taken another lover.
再说了，我喜欢冷。30年后，我收到一张明信片。我有一个儿子。他是警察局长。故事从这里开始变得有趣。我告诉蒂芙尼在巴黎的特罗卡德罗（Trocadero）见我。这些年她一直在等我。她从未找过其他情人。
I don't care.
I don't show up.
I go to Berlin.
That's where I stashed the chandelier.
Oh, Berlin.
That's why these are like final questions because he says Paris and Berlin,
he doesn't say France and Germany, but he says Mexico and Canada.
Oh.
我不在乎。我没有出现。我去了柏林。那是我藏水晶灯的地方。哦，柏林。这就是为什么这些问题像是终极问题，因为他说的是巴黎和柏林，他没有说法国和德国，但他说的是墨西哥和加拿大。哦。
They ask for countries.
See, they're tricky.
They are tricky.
To give us some credit, Jack, these are questions in the final round of the final, what did you call it?
National Office trivia championship.
Come on.
We're doing good for that.
Over 700 teams have competed to get to this moment.
他们问的是国家。看，他们很狡猾。确实很狡猾。为了给我们自己挽尊，杰克，这些可是决赛轮中的最后问题，你管这叫什么来着？全国《办公室》知识问答锦标赛。拜访啦。我们答得已经很不错了。超过700支队伍竞争才走到这一刻。
I mean, that's insane.
I have a question for you guys.
Yes.
This is not trivia.
This is just a fun one.
This is what we would call our office question of the week.
This is from Lena C in Germany who says,
which invention of Michael Scott do you think could actually be successful in real life if you had to pick one?
我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我有一个问题要问你们。是的。这不是知识问答。这只是一个有趣的问题。这就是我们所谓的“本周办公室问题”。这是来自德国的莉娜·C（Lena C）提出的，她说，如果必须选一个，你认为迈克尔·斯科特的哪一项发明在现实生活中真正能成功？
Would you pick Shulala, chair pants, toilet buddy, Mike Serial Shack, or Threat Level Midnight, the movie?
I really like Mike Serial Shack.
That's very intriguing to me.
Also, it's a really cute name.
Yeah.
The pants chair.
Honestly, I remember watching it being like, this is like 1% a good idea.
Yeah, if there was a way to make the chair pants like not uncomfortable to walk around in, where it was like totally normal pants.
你会选舒啦啦（Shulala）、椅子裤（chair pants）、马桶好伙伴（toilet buddy）、迈克麦片屋（Mike Serial Shack），还是电影《威胁最高级别午夜》（Threat Level Midnight）？我真的很喜欢迈克麦片屋。这对我很有吸引力。而且，名字真的很可爱。是的。椅子裤。老实说，我记得看的时候就在想，这有1%的好点子。是的，如果有一种方法能让椅子裤穿起来走路不觉得难受，就像完全正常的裤子一样。
But then if you sat down, it became a chair.
You know, as a parent who is often going to like kids sporting events, where there isn't a chair.
if I could just wear my chair pants.
Yeah, right?
Really, you guys, I am surprised
no one has chosen toilet buddy.
You don't want to go to the bathroom
through a strainer?
但如果你坐下，它就变成了一把椅子。你知道的，作为一个经常去看像儿童体育赛事这样的活动、而那里又没有椅子的家长，如果我能直接穿上我的椅子裤。是的，对吧？真的，伙计们，我很惊讶居然没有人选马桶好伙伴。你不想通过滤网去上厕所吗？
I think there's...
Just so your stuff doesn't fall in.
That is one of my favorite Michael moments.
It was deleted.
It was added back to the super fan episode.
You can see it in all its glory.
Is there anything else, Jack,
that we need to do in terms of trivia?
我觉得有……这样你的东西就不会掉进去了。那是我最喜欢的迈克尔的高光时刻之一。它被删减了。后来又被加回了粉丝特别版剧集里。你可以看到它的全部风采。还有什么吗，杰克，我们需要在知识问答方面做的？
Do you want three rapid fire from...
Okay, three rapid fire.
Let's be easy.
It's the most fun thing ever.
So yeah.
Okay, okay.
This is a really rapid fire.
Ready?
你想从……来三个快问快答吗？好的，来三个快问快答。简单点。这是最有趣的事。所以，是的。好的，好的。这个真的是快问快答。准备好了吗？
Okay.
On the wall of Mr. Chu's Chinese restaurant, who was in a photo holding up a sign that said thief?
Breed.
Yep.
Who did Dwight think takes 50 minutes to style his hair?
Yes.
Jim.
Okay.
好的。在朱先生中餐馆的墙上，谁在一张举着写着“小偷”牌子的照片里？克里德。没错。德怀特觉得谁花50分钟弄头发？是的。吉姆。好的。
Sorry, I couldn't even read the question.
All right.
One more.
Who was only a little stitious?
Michael.
Yay.
Can't get enough.
抱歉，我甚至都来不及读题。好吧。还有一个。谁只是有点迷信？迈克尔。迈克尔。耶。根本不够玩。
We clearly could do this all damn day because it's so fun.
Jack, love you so much.
Thank you for getting on.
I literally love you so much.
I'm honored to meet you guys.
Thanks so much for having me.
Jack, you're amazing at trivia.
You guys should enter a competition.
我们显然可以这样玩上一整天，因为太有趣了。杰克，太爱你了。谢谢你连线。我真的超级超级爱你。我很荣幸能见到你们。非常感谢邀请我。杰克，你太擅长知识问答了。你们俩应该去参加个比赛。
By the way, he also has a whole song about the office and how his life and relationships
have just completely been told through the story of the office throughout his life.
And it's out and you can listen to it.
What is the name of this song?
What is the name of the song?
A Netflix trip.
I know it.
I know that song.
顺便说一下，他还写了一整首歌，关于《办公室》，以及他一生中的生活和人际关系是如何完全通过《办公室》的故事来讲述的。这首歌已经发行了，大家可以去听听。这首歌叫什么名字？这首歌叫什么名字？《Netflix之旅》（A Netflix trip）。我知道。我知道那首歌。
I think you guys have actually talked about it.
We've talked about it.
We played it on the podcast.
Oh, did you really?
I think I played it.
Yeah.
That's you?
That's me and my brothers.
我觉得你们其实聊过它。我们聊过。我们在播客里放过它。哦，真的吗？我想我放过。是的。那是你？那是我和我兄弟们。
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Yes, it's so wonderful.
I want to play some of it.
I had my forest crush in season two.
She passed me notes and fill our hands with glue.
Aww
是的，是的。哦，天哪。是的，太棒了。我想放一点。我在第二季有了我的初恋。她给我传纸条，把我们的手涂满胶水。啊
To school
I sat and crossed my legs like chin would do
Aww
She moved away
I was on season three
It hit my heart so hard I'd have me speak
But I could find some peace in privacy
A paper company to sell with me
我坐在学校里，像吉姆那样盘起腿。啊 她搬走了，我正看第三季 它深深触动我的心，让我无言以对 但我能在独处中找到一些平静 一家卖纸给我、和我一起的造纸公司
still with me. So sweet. Thank you guys so much. And that's awesome. You guys have both written songs.
It's true. With the office. It's true. And the office themes. That's kind of, it wouldn't be who we are without the show.
It's pretty cool. We wouldn't be friends without the office. It bonded us. Well, listen, we always are humbled by the fact that our show brings people together.
And I know you feel that way about your music, both of you. And thank you so much for taking the time to come here
today. We love you guys. We love you. We want you to come back anytime you want. For real.
No, seriously, you have to stop saying that because you don't want me to come back so many because I'm going to literally...
You know what you should do? You tell us an episode that you want to break down with us. And we'll break down an episode with you.
You can pick a super fan. Oh, my God, done. Literally done. Let's do it.
依然和我在一起。太甜了。非常感谢你们。太棒了。你们俩都写过歌。确实如此。关于《办公室》的。确实如此。还有办公室主题。这某种程度上，没有这部剧就没有现在的我们。这真的很酷。没有《办公室》我们就不会成为朋友。它把我们联系在了一起。好吧，听着，我们的节目能把人们聚在一起，这让我们总是感到谦逊和荣幸。我知道你们对你们的音乐也有这种感觉，你们两个都是。非常感谢你们今天花时间来到这里。我们爱你们。我们爱你们。我们希望你们随时想来就来。说真的。不，说真的，你别再这么说了，因为你不会想让我经常回来的，因为我真的会……你知道你应该做什么吗？你告诉我们你想和我们一起剖析哪一集。然后我们和你一起剖析一集。你可以挑一集粉丝特别版。哦，天哪，说定了。绝对说定了。我们干吧。
Yeah. There we go. All right. Thank you for coming.
Bye guys. Bye. Wow. I know. I still can't believe it happened. I still can't get over the fact that she is such a
a big office ladies fan.
She's also just a wonderful human being.
Yes.
And such a fun person to be around.
And just gives her all to you.
I know.
好的。就这样。好吧。谢谢你们来。再见，各位。再见。哇。我知道。我还是不敢相信这一切发生了。我还是无法接受她居然是《办公室女士》的超级大粉丝。她也只是个很棒的人。是的。是一个相处起来非常有趣的人。而且对你倾其所有。我知道。
I just, I really like her as a person.
Yeah.
I mean, she is so accomplished and so talented,
but she's also just a fantastic human being.
Yeah.
And super smart.
Oh, and I really loved her dog shark.
He tried to eat the granola bar in my back.
我真的很喜欢她这个人。是的。我的意思是，她如此成功，如此有才华，但她同时也是个绝佳的人。是的。而且超级聪明。哦，我真的很喜欢她的狗鲨鱼（Shark）。它试图吃掉我包里的格兰诺拉麦片棒。
But next time I'll bring treats.
Okay, Billy.
you come back, we're going to have treats for Shark.
I also want to give a big thank you to Will Allen for helping me prepare our office
trivia quiz. And I want to give a shout out because Will is currently starring as Dr. Thomas Stockman
and Amy Herzog's adaptation of an enemy of the people at the stunning new timeline
theater in Chicago. You can get tickets at timelinetheater.com. I saw this in New York.
It's a great show. And also, we would love to thank Jack Metzker for calling in
但下次我会带零食的。好吧，比利。你再来的时候，我们会为鲨鱼准备零食。我还要向威尔·艾伦（Will Allen）表示巨大的感谢，感谢他帮我准备我们的办公室问答测验。我还要特别喊话一下，因为威尔目前正在芝加哥惊艳的全新时间线剧院（Timeline Theater）上演的艾米·赫尔佐格（Amy Herzog）改编的《人民公敌》中饰演托马斯·斯托克曼医生（Dr. Thomas Stockman）。你可以在 timelinetheater.com 买到票。我在纽约看过这个剧。这是一部很棒的剧。另外，我们要非常感谢杰克·梅茨格（Jack Metzger）连线
to do trivia with Billy, and that was so cool to find out that he wrote the song
Netflix trip about his love of The Office. I know. I couldn't believe that. I'm like,
I know that song. You're like, it's you. And oh my goodness, thank you so much to Billy Eilish
for being an office ladies, listener and fan. I hope you like this episode, Billy. Hi.
Hi, Billy. How are you doing? Are you listening to us right now? Are you in your house?
Maybe hanging some pictures. I know. Are you cleaning up something, maybe folding laundry?
Maybe you're just in the car.
We don't know.
和比利一起做知识问答，知道他写了《Netflix之旅》这首歌来表达他对《办公室》的热爱，真是太酷了。我知道。我简直不敢相信。我当时就想，我知道那首歌。你就说，原来是你。哦天哪，非常感谢比利·艾利什（Billy Eilish）成为《办公室女士》的听众和粉丝。希望你喜欢这一集，比利。嗨。嗨，比利。你好吗？你现在在听我们说话吗？你在家里吗？也许在挂几幅画。我知道。你在打扫什么东西吗，也许在叠衣服？也许你正坐在车里。我们不知道。
Yeah.
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
We will be back next week with a very special guest from the Office cast.
We're going to be chatting with Calvin Tenor who played Glenn from the warehouse.
All right.
See you then.
好的。谢谢大家。我们下周将带着来自《办公室》演员阵容的一位非常特别的嘉宾回归。我们将与扮演仓库员工格伦（Glenn）的卡尔·特纳（Calvin Tenor）聊天。好的。到时见。到时见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed in.
mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Odyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle），我们的音频工程师是萨姆·法伊弗（Sam Pfeiffer）。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Puppetry》。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森（Kelly Clarkson），与Wayfair合作。
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit Wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.
你有没有在网上订购过家具，然后心里犯嘀咕：万一呢？比如，万一它不结实呢？那张沙发才买四天。你当时真该在Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜爱的风格和你可以信赖的质量。请访问 Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，演绎每种风格，点亮每个家。